la première règle est de ne pas s'auto
bullshit et et c'est pas facile parce
que vous êtes la personne la plus facile
à bullshit et donc cette situation et de
richard suzman et je pense qu'elle est
il quelque chose extrêmement profond on
a tendance à penser que ce sont des
autres qui bullshit que ce sont les
autres qui nous ou le site en
particulier mais peut-être le plus gros
danger
en fait même très certainement après
beaucoup de travaux en psychologie
le plus gros danger en fait c'est les
bobards qu'on se raconte même pas aux
autres mais à nous mêmes tout ce qu'on
se raconte pour se conforter notamment
dans nos propres opinions
il semble que ce soit ça la principale
cause des erreurs de raisonnement
alors on pourrait croire que la solution
du coup pour éviter de s'auto bullshit
et c'est plus d'éducation mais comme ici
très bien alexandre dans cette vidéo
était dû à galets d'entrée conférence
alors fait très loin d'être très très
clair on déjà vu un lien entre un des
grands paris dans la salle espère
démocratie en fait si la sécu puna
d'éducation plus ou moins de moyens pour
défendre dans n'importe quelle idée et
du coup dans si on apprend via cultive
tout ça car plus de façon de critiquer
les idées que l'on n'aime pas et ça ça
en fait au moins de notre capacité à
bullshit et et en particulier à une
photo bullshit et donc il est vraiment
pas clair que plus d'éducation permettra
d'avoir de moins sotto voce et du coup
d'avoir des croyances plus honnête une
certaine manière
et carrément c'est pas facile de
détecter son propre bullshit on est très
sensible aux bruits des hôtes mais c'est
compliqué d'être sensible notre propre
bouche et surtout si c'est juste dit
pour nous qu'il est en tout cas moi j'ai
beaucoup de mal ça m'est arrivé pardon
peu récemment dans une transaction que
j'ai donné à sciences po sur l'éthique
de lille où j'ai donné cet exemple dont
j'avais parlé également dans sur scène
ce soir lorsqu'on fait docteur enfin
quand on demande n ya qu est ce que fait
docteur moi sommes plus fun il répond
infirmières et c'était un peu malhonnête
ces thèmes car le moment les nets devin
par alors pas à l'époque pour que j'ai
fait cette vidéo c'est tel titre
mais quand je l'aï refaite quand j'ai
fait la présentation à sciences po il ya
quelques les quelques mois en fait
c'était vraiment un mensonge de ma part
puisque entre temps
en 2010 neuf s'ils ne font pas eu un
article qui faisait la remarque que en
fait ce cas est due à un artefact qu'on
a demandé ali à ango 91 à lire de dire
ce que faisait docteur moi sommes plus
forts mais on l'avait interdit de dire
docteur du coup on a été un peu obligé
de trouver un truc différent de docteurs
et qui correspond un peu à ça et c'est
donc pour ça qu'il donne avec qui il a
donné la réponse infirmières alors petit
renard qui a quand même pas mal d'autres
articles qui montrent de manière
différente
le genre de billet qui peuvent
apparaître lorsqu'on fait du traitement
automatisé du langage mais en tout cas
voilà c'était malhonnête de ma part
quelqu'un me l'a fait remarquer juste
après et j'ai été un peu en mode
multitâches et oui on a fait à raison
mais il me semblait que c'était utile
quand même parce que ça ça ça cache
quelque chose de plus fondamental qui
sont aidées algorithmique et en effet il
ya près d oublier la golding plus
fondamentale avec pas mal d'autres
exemples qui illustrent mais cet exemple
est juste un mauvais exemple et
l'utiliser comme ça c'est passé juste
malhonnête de ma part
et alors là j'ai eu de la chance parce
que c'est un bolide public du coup bas
il ya quelqu'un qui a pu faire la
remarque et j'ai pu corriger quoi ça
fait réfléchir
mais c'est beaucoup plus difficile quand
c'est du bullshit à soi même
longtemps par exemple je me suis
bullshit et sur l'importance des maths
de la recherche en match de la recherche
en matière c'est super important ça
permet plein de trucs fous en fait ça si
on analyse vraiment les conséquences des
différents trucs
il ya quand même pas mal d'arguments
pour dire que oui c'est bien la
recherche en maths mais c'est loin
d'être aussi important que que ce que ce
que j'imaginais
bref l'honnêteté intellectuelle c'est
pas facile c'est vraiment vraiment pas
facile et en particulier se l'appliquer
à soi-même être honnête
intellectuellement bas
probablement si on essaye juste comme ça
on n'y arrivera pas il faut vraiment du
travail de l'exercice et s'habituer à
chercher à être honnête
intellectuellement
alors comment être honnête
intellectuellement comment y arriver
bah je pense que la clé c'est pas
vraiment la volonté quand on donne
beaucoup trop d'importance à à la
volonté c'est important à volonté il
faut avancer pour faire changer les
choses mais finalement la volonté on
allait limiter et on est motivés au fait
ce métier quand on est en mode mois plus
mais on finit souvent par basculer en
mode zombie est en mode zombie ça c'est
un peu fini il ya plus de volonté et du
coup plutôt que miser sur la volonté
je pense que c'est ce que défend j'ai la
galère et je pense qu'elle a raison et
il est vraiment davantage pertinent de
travailler sur les motivations implicite
et en particulier les récompenses que
l'on reçoit si on reçoit des récompenses
pour bullshit et il va on va prendre
l'habitude de bullshit et si on soit
décoré compense pour être honnête
intellectuellement et bien on va prendre
l'habitude d'être honnête
intellectuellement tout cas ça sera plus
facile de le devenir
et du coup vous invite à vraiment
réfléchir à quelles sont les récompenses
que vous recevez et que vous donnez
également
est ce que ces récompenses motive les
gens à être plus honnête
intellectuellement ou est ce qui les
encourage les gens à davantage bullshit
et malheureusement il ya beaucoup de
milieux où j'ai l'impression que c'est
plutôt le second s'encourager un peu à
bouchité parce que j'ai des convictions
il faut les défendre coûte que coûte
et si c'est le cas on risque vraiment de
publicité et c'était mon cas alors ce
que faisait part d'un pub l'apologie de
la recherche en mathématiques
je m'étais entouré d'autres gens qui
faisait également la plongée de
mathématiques et pour lucky bouchité été
ambiant a été tout à fait acceptable et
acceptée et al'inverse une honnêteté
intellectuelle un esprit beaucoup plus
critique le fait de reconnaître qu'on a
exagéré les trucs mettre les bémols tout
ce qu'on dit
c'était pas si récompensé que ça vous
invite à faire gaffe à ça donc il ya la
fois directement ce que vous pouvez vous
donner à vous même
ce que vous dites sg j'avais raison
lorsque chaque fois que vous avez j'ai
gagné un débat quand vous arrivez à
biabou agitée où est ce que vous vous
dites plus là j'ai eu de la chance mais
là sur cet autre coup en fait non je me
suis planté
si vous n'êtes plus dans ce second trucs
et vous dites ah bah c'est cool que je
me sois à planter parce que ça me fait
réfléchir ça me serait plutôt que je
découvre que que je me sois planté
découvrir une erreur récurrente que l'on
fait ça doit être associée à une réponse
positive
si on veut à être davantage honnête
intellectuellement et au sort il ya
également les récompenses social de
notre entourage
et là pour le coup c'est du coup je
pense vraiment utile de réfléchir à son
entourage
quels sont les récompenses que donne son
entourage pour reprendre l'exemple de
l'est qui défendent est là aux
chercheurs en mathématiques faisait
l'apologie de la recherche en
mathématiques de façon ne semble bien
trop exagéré il s'était aussi entouré de
tout un microcosme qui encouragent et ça
et du coup bah c'était pas cool ah oui
j'oubliais les paris mais paris c'est
aussi une excellente façon de se rendre
compte de ce qu'on pense vraiment du
coup d'être plus honnête
intellectuellement
si vous pensez que vous citez sur un
truc dites-vous ok mais combien je suis
prêt à parier sur ça pas besoin de
parler publiquement mais vraiment parié
honnêtement écrivit sa sur un bout de
papier puis fait le bilan des pareils
que vous avez fait c'est une façon de se
rendre compte à quel point on bullshit
et en partie quand est-ce qu'on bullshit
beaucoup trop
bref l'honnêteté intellectuelle c'est
vraiment cool c'est vraiment pas facile
et pour y arriver
bah il faut jouer sans doute suivre les
récompenses que l'on se donne et qu'on
donne aux autres parfois certains
parlent du point de l'auto alignement et
bien l'auto alignement d'olivia
l'honnêteté intellectuelle
c'est quelque chose qui se parent est
absolument indispensable